bonjour didier combo merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors vous
avez assisté comme nous à ce débat entre
jabba d'enjoy données et donald trump on
a plus l'impression d'avoir assisté à un
règlement de compte avec des attaques en
règle plutôt qu un débat de fond c'est
aussi votre avis oui tout à fait à la
presse américaine et internationale
d'ailleurs etc unanimes sur la question
c'était un débat extrêmement chaotique
où les sujets de fond n'ont été
qu'effleuré le modérateur chris wallace
a dû un grand nombre de fois à appeler
trump a respecté les règles kiki qui ont
été définies par les deux campagnes
c'est à dire si tu aimes et au début de
chaque thème et chaque candidat pouvait
s'explose s'exprimer pendant deux
minutes sans interruption et trompe pas
eu beaucoup de mal à respecter cette
règle et hayden en a fait les frais la
job as et n'a pas non plus mâché ses
mots alors sedan lors de ce débat il
avait avant ce débat un petit peu
d'avancé dans l'est dans les sondages
est ce que à votre avis ce débat peut
lui avoir fait perdre des points à mon
avis c'est peu probable alors il est
vrai que by john avait plus à perdre à
ce débat que trump n'avait à gagner et
l'enjeu pour l'enjeu pour byden était
justement de pouvoir faire face à au
caractère de trump et à ces
interruptions et il y a finalement assez
bien réussi je crois que la presse est
assez unanime sur ce sujet aussi il a
réussi à ne pas perdre son calme
il n'a pas pu mettre des dossiers que
trump et il est quand même
il s'est quand même bien défendus
vis-à-vis de trump il est ici il a su
également se montrer agressif en le
traitant de cloud en le traitant de
menteur et donc finalement il donne a
relativement bien résisté à s'était pas
alors il y aura d'autres sera
certainement insuffisant pour convaincre
les indécis
il y aura d'autres débats télévisés
entre entre les deux hommes est ce qu'on
peut imaginer que les prochains seront
identiques on peut on peut se sont
inquiétés et il ya par exemple une revue
d atlantic qui appelle à l'annulation
des prochains débats étant donné la
qualité de ce premier débat est l'enjeu
2-2
de tels débats ça n'est pas tant de
faire changer les gens d'avis ceux qui
ont décidé de voter soit pour crème de
soin pour bayonne
ce sera difficile de les faire changer
d'avis l'enjeu c'est de convaincre des
indécis et dans la mesure où il y avait
très peu de fonds dans ce débat il est
assez peu probable que les que les
indécis change d'avis les les deux
challengers ce sont finalement apparu
tels qu'on les connaît un donald trump
une très forte personnalité et puis
l'autre côté by john quelqu'un de plus
réfléchi et de plus posé et c'est
finalement les candidats qu'on
connaissait déjà donc on n'a pas grand
chose vous parlais tout à l'heure de
chris wallace j'en ai de foxnews 1 qui a
arbitré entre guillemets ce débat entre
entre les deux hommes est ce que c'est à
lui à ce journaliste justement de faire
un peu respecté les règles oui bien sûr
mais je crois que le valeureux a fait ce
qu'il a pu
et il l'a rappelé à plusieurs reprises
ses règles et puis il a aussi dit un
certain moment que les américains
étaient en attente de quelque chose de
plus substantiel du débat mais
malheureusement ça lui a été très
difficile d'arriver à conduire ce débat
pour que ce soit un débat du niveau
d'une présidentielle est ce que votre
avis on peut éventuellement sortir un
vainqueur de ce premier rendez vous
écouter dire qu'il ya un vainqueur ce
serait beaucoup dire d'ailleurs la
presse deux sacres personnes vainqueur
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que bill donne
a mieux résisté que ce à quoi on pouvait
s'attendre il faut dire que les attentes
étaient assez peu élevé du côté de bail
dunn et on pouvait craindre qu'il soit
laminé par train et il n'a pas été
laminé par trump donc on en est
finalement à la fin du débat un petit
peu au même point qu'au début merci
beaucoup didier combo d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes chercheur associé à
l'institut des amériques et auteur
d'être américain aujourd'hui les enjeux
d'une élection présidentielle merci
beaucoup